today we're going to start the hour with
this breaking news in the fight against
the coronavirus modernist says
it's asking the fda today for emergency
use authorization for its vaccine
the u.s now has had more than 13 million
reported cases of the virus
more than 266 000 people have already
died
and at least 4.2 million of those cases
have been diagnosed in november and
that's double
the november the number rather from last
month so covert related hospitalizations
are also at their highest point
ever that's nearly one hundred thousand
people are hospitalized today
officials warn it could soon get even
worse with what they're calling a surge
upon a surge
after thanksgiving here's white house
task force member dr deborah burks
we're entering this post thanksgiving
surge
with three four and ten times as much
disease
across the country and so that's what
worries us the most
in new york mayor bill de blasio
announced some schools there will be
reopening
he closed schools earlier this month due
to rising case numbers
and we're joined now by health and human
services secretary alex zazar secretary
azar good to be with you this morning
thank you for joining us
we've got good news and bad news on the
coronavirus the bad news is we're losing
about a person a minute
to this disease the good news is there's
help on the way so i want to start there
the moderna vaccine emergency use
application went in today
pfizer has already put theirs in how
soon what day
of the month of december could we see an
actual shot
going into somebody's arm in this
country so tony as you mentioned a week
ago
pfizer submitted their application for
emergency authorization and then moderna
today
is going to be submitting with pfizer we
at the fda announced an advisory
committee for december the 10th and if
everything is on track
everything proves out what uh what it
appears to be
we could be looking at approval within
days after that moderna is basically one
week behind that
and general purna has said from
operation warp speed that
we'll ship within 24 hours of fda
authorization so
we could be seeing both of these
vaccines out uh and getting
into people's arms uh before christmas
so let's talk about who's going to get
it talk to me about the priority who
gets it first who gets it second and so
on
so we are still running a very public
process to seek the best scientific uh
expert opinion here so we have at the
cdc something called the advisory
committee
on immunization practices and they have
been meeting with us to give us advice
on whom based on the data that we've got
on these vaccines
and the state of the case the
epidemiology around the country
should we vaccinate first that's ongoing
still
i hope this week we'll get greater
clarity from them in terms of their
recommendations and our cdc director's
views
but be thinking people in nursing homes
the most vulnerable
be thinking healthcare workers who are
on the front lines of most interacting
with suspected
covid cases as the first tranches of
people that will try to get vaccinated
now
the federal government will ship to the
states and then you've said governors
will have ultimate authority about who
gets the vaccine
first if you see at the federal level
certain states where
people are jumping the line either
because they have money or they have
connections
is there something that's going to
happen to stop that
well again we're not going to be
shipping vaccine to the states i do want
to be clear about that we're shipping it
through the normal vaccine distribution
system
our governors are really like air
traffic controllers they're going to
tell us
which hospital which pharmacies where
they would like it to go
and they will be determining which
groups to be prioritized i would hope
that the science and the evidence will
be clear enough that our governors will
follow the recommendations that we will
make to them and we'll certainly call
out any any
inequities or injustices that we see in
approach
and we'll assess all of our options as
we go but i've got great confidence i'll
be talking to all the nation's governors
this afternoon with the vice president
i've i've got a lot of confidence on our
governors to do the right thing here
all right calling it out in inequities
let's talk about the messaging uh you
know
about half the population has said
according to polls that they may not
take this vaccine they're worried
what is our national strategy for
educating the public about the safety of
the vaccine and getting people to
actually take this thing
yep so we've got a very large public
affairs campaign in the works i hope
that we'll be on radio this week
and then getting on tv soon thereafter
to help educate people about these
these vaccines you know tony one
interesting thing we've actually had to
go back to the to as we call it the
white boarding on the
on on these campaigns because the modern
and physical vaccines are
so highly effective in these clinical
trials
we've actually had to make some edits to
our campaign materials to to take
account of that
and then the most important thing we're
doing is we're keeping politics out of
the process
and we're making sure that everything is
done through those independent checks
in the system that you and i have talked
about so often can you tell us more
about these campaigns because they are
so critical i know you think that i know
that the biden team thinks that
i would certainly agree what's going to
be in these campaigns and are they
targeted in particular
to populations i'm thinking black and
brown populations more vulnerable
populations
who are particularly skeptical about
something coming through a federal
process
yeah there is a targeting there because
as you know there's a very sad and sorry
history
in connection with uh with some aspects
of clinical trial research that have
happened in the past that's why we've
been so focused
so very focused to ensure significant
minority community enrollment in these
clinical trials and the latest moderna
data out today from the
full clinical trial uh demonstrate i
think 30 percent of those in the trials
were
from underserved communities especially
our african-american and our latinx
community so we have a very robust
population that participated in the
studies and i just want to say as
secretary
thank you to everybody who's
participated in these clinical trials
you really give us hope for the future
because of these incredible vaccines
that
now we're going to be coming secretary
azar i don't mean to to second guess you
so late in the process here but
you say you're working on a messaging
campaign wouldn't the time for the
messaging campaign
have been now and prior so while you're
working on logistics while you're
developing
during that period i started educating
yeah no actually tony not
first off we wanted to be very sensitive
you know the other side was complaining
if we were to put campaigns
out uh to educate people about the
vaccine before the election there was a
lot of concern expressed about that
we held those campaigns back but also
you want to time it just right
you can't condition a market a month two
months before general vaccine
availability you just won't have the
effect so you want to time it
really right in sequence with vaccine
availability so that you
that you really have that call to action
that will have the maximum effect so the
timing is right on
all right we're all hoping it works out
alex azar thank you very much we
appreciate it
thank you